et je vous le disais les enjeux
technologiques sont colossaux il n'aura
fallu que cinq ans pour construire
l'a380 une vraie course contre la montre
qui aura mobilisé des milliers
d'ouvriers et d'ingénieurs à travers
toute leur patrice pollet et
jean-jacques le gac la fabrication de
l'a380 est un vrai défi logistique parce
qu'il est fabriqué dans quatre pays
différents
en angleterre les moteurs et les ailes
en allemagne et en france le fuselage
en espagne la dérive arrière pour finir
tout est acheminé vers toulouse où
l'avion est assemblé et chaque pièce
suivie avec attention par ses
concepteurs
les usines envoient leurs personnels qui
sont qualifiés compétents sur ces
éléments là pour les mettre au propre
jusqu'à au premier volet après
l'imagination des ingénieurs n'a pas
manqué pour faire parvenir les pièces
jusqu'à toulouse des bateaux
spécialement aménagée ont transporté les
tronçons depuis l'allemagne
le long des routes on a coupé des arbres
arrachés des panneaux est bien calculé
la largeur des convois pour qu'ils
puissent passer de jour comme de nuit
il a fallu aussi attendre que l'eau des
fleuves soit au plus bas pour passer
sous les ponts
finalement le premier avion sera bien
construit dans les temps nos hangars
géants la taille du monstre qui affiche
des dimensions impressionnantes 80 m de
large
75 de long si on le mettait debout
l'a380 dépasserait notre-dame de 4 mai
le résultat une machine capable
d'emporter entre 500 et 800 passagers
selon les versions
une révolution dans le monde du
transport aérien avec une masse au
décollage de 550 tonnes
le tout posé sur 22 août au delà de
l'aspect technique c'est à dire réussir
à faire décoller un avion de plus de 500
tonnes
il ya aussi l'aspect historique l'europe
unie va fabriquer le plus gros avion du
monde